what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we are back for secret
Invasion episode five today John how's
it going I am great how are you doing
well coy so excited to see who dies and
comes back ladies and gentlemen you know
what to do please go ahead leave a like
on this video my gosh there's a good
case for why this show is great oh I am
setting us up for a transition to
something we agreed to before the strike
commenced so it is okay according to the
rules
hey Webheads we got a spectacular
sponsor today in case the fire here to
tell you anybody can be a hero you don't
even need a radioactive spider
introducing the Spider-Man X case defy
collection turning your phone into a
piece of the Marvel Universe the
Spider-Man mask case is no less than
your very own super suit reminding us
all we've got the power to swing into
action and make a difference but if
you're feeling a tad symbiotic the Venom
pattern case is right up your alley it's
some of that classic better matchiness
give your phone a touch of anti-hero
chic or if you're feeling the need for
some flip Splat sap action the
Spider-Man pattern case is as close as
it gets to having spidey's classic
banter in your pocket and of course you
can't forget the classic Spider-Man
hanging case echoing the Timeless wisdom
with great power comes great
responsibility I mean my favorite pick
it's got to be the Spider-Man mask case
but how about you ready to thrip into
action with your very own hashtag
Spider-Man X casify case don't hang
around like a radioactive spider swing
over to the link in the description box
for the Spider-Man X case defy
collection make sure you tag your
webtacular selfies with you everything
you're seeing on screen right now until
next time
stay spectacular
oh yeah and I should probably mention
we're gonna be at Comic-Con this
Saturday one o'clock P.M the Neo
Auditorium I think is what it's called
if you're going to Comic-Con please stop
by would love to see you there can you
hear me
so you need to make a space this was not
the Russians it was not sir the hospital
is full of Scrolls so do you have
clearance
then stay outside
but even when he's out he's in
that yeah
it's a great shot
this guy
I like him remember his name everyone ah
yeah but you know
you should be proud G
it calls him G
should be proud homie yeah dude you
ordered Fury's death when you knew Vara
would never do it you had another chance
to kill Fury today and you didn't take
it you're weak G makes me start to
wonder why should we whoa yeah
definitely did not see that coming
whoa
graphic and the only reason Fury was on
that Motorway was because his traitor
wife
to fight my director she traded you and
you send some of our people to vara's
house and kill her
everyone go kill her
I'd like to order a pizza place
extra pepperoni make sure he knows it
wasn't just the Russians who did this it
was the Russians with the help of
Scrolls
what
prove to him there are Scrolls living
here in Russia and that they must all be
eliminated war and if we don't get what
we want
well then we all do what we've prepared
for
sacrifice
G your plan gets more confusing by the
second where's the president
damn people's just giving out classified
information lock this whole place down
right now
he's in a suit he's in a suit calm down
do something
your service to the president tonight
but I'm here now you can go
and be out of your scroll ass man
in about 60 seconds the footage of you
killing Maria Hill is gonna get off
every news program all across the
hemisphere 60 seconds you're gonna
become the most wanted and hated man
on the planet the people love Maria so
Tick Tock Nick
it's
ouch
could have just also shot him consider
this a preview Nick because if you ever
get within 100 yards of the president
again
I'm gonna make sure you get the whole
show go grab it I'm coming for him
tell him yourself it is fun to watch
these two squirrels admittedly this is a
short run time so I'm starting to get
worried already got the penultimate
episode's only 40 minutes 39 minutes
with the official run time minus credits
minus recap all right minus ending
credits wow yeah they've got to do a lot
fictional city of London
I wish I could go there good afternoon
Sonia have you heard about this was it
trolls could be amongst us well if you
ask me sir I think they're bloody
everywhere
oh
politely asking the location of Dr Rosa
Dalton have you lost your mind woman
showing director weatherby's true colors
the last inform you that the sis has no
official policy on killing Scrolls
to enact my personal preference right
now you should stop talking
yeah I'm just happy when she's sunscreen
it's on your mind soldier I was just a
little confused
are you confused about can I not call
you g
once he's awake I'll send confirmation
of the strike yeah
because you know what happens if you
don't run
yeah I was wondering about that new
today
grew tan your way through this man yeah
I guess
or other abilities that have yet to be
uncovered Frost giant skills something
at least
take his pants off
tickle him
oh
cool that was cool that was really cool
wow
nice hit
this episode got stunts
man you guys suck there's like so many
I'm nothing but a monster
ha
all right
a mask sure does look funny
it's a big old Noggin
that way the ears were bouncing
what the hell you doing
Talos died
he's not dead he died on a foreign
planet on a foreign Road
nothing will come of it
Revenge because I knew he would lose
Talos chose the path of struggle he did
not lose
you cannot let grief paralyze you Gaia
this is your time now
she just started grieving
what DNA did Robert steal
only a few samples collapsody and Flora
Colossus
what was he looking for
something he called the Harvest
what's the Harvest it's a big pumpkin I
need to bury my father
take him to Priscilla she'll know what
to do
oh it's like the siren started
right outside that window
surprise him
he'll never find us here
hello Scrolls
who are you
I think a more apt question would be who
would you like me to be I'm staggeringly
versatile I'm very good at being your
bestie I'm also devilishly good at being
not your bestie it's really just a
matter of taste Cake or Death
Nigel and my name's Victor
Nigel's the one with his silencer
pressed against the base of your skull
[Music]
now start from the very beginning and
don't miss out a damn decimal point
really is a lovely laboratory
unfortunately I'm going to have to
torches blow it
well done Nigel
which has now been overtaken by Lucifer
as a more popular baby name let us go or
a killer males in my species are very
similar if they're not busy gaslighting
you they're threatening you as murder
that's what all the podcasts are about
hey woke whoa
she ain't wrong I liked her until she
started shoving agendas down my throat
just talking points of the liberal Elite
she's gonna save Priscilla
[Music]
so adorable she's such a small person I
know
I'm Gaia Theory said you could help me
bury my father
Heavenly music that sort of play oh
Mr President what you see on the screen
is the squirrel compound that's Russian
soil we have to neutralize this facility
I would rather us face a war than
Extinction and that's exactly what a
scroll Invasion will mean we have to cut
this thing off the head do you never put
on your armor suit Rhody
you're never just like I'll handle it I
can probably do that real quick yeah
but I won't carpet on this one little
location permission I got a deal for you
got anything to do with the Harvest
bring it to me in person I'll call the
whole thing off
if I don't get what I want your
president's going to bomb new scrollers
bring some iodide pills the reactor room
can be touch aggressive sure I guess
y'all radiated up
[Applause]
I feel a lot better if we were on the
helical yeah that's been mothballed a
little bit like you should be oh
voila figured you might need that on the
other side
you're welcome that's a call back try
and get a nap leave my little grumpy
spin-off he deserves a procession of
mourners Dallas wasn't much for a
pageantry do you have the offering
I feel like the first few episodes are a
lot more strikingly shot it's kind of
going back to sort of a general
Blanchard simpler way of shooting I
wonder if it's like they shoot in
chronological order and just budget or
time or they get tired it's hot sleep no
I'll just put the camera anywhere
insubordination I guess and yet you
decided to obey the audio that says you
have to wait around here for your
execution the thing is I love this house
it's got a lot of equity in it I wasn't
sure if he'd ever commit to calling any
one place home that need to find a place
that offered the three things he valued
most
lots of privacy lots of security
and lots of leather
light where's the playroom he'd sit
there by the window reading a book
letting the sun kiss his skin freaking
out how he couldn't see out of one eye
he ever get lost watching you in your
own skin that's none of your business
you don't know what it takes to build a
life with someone else to sustain it
to buy all this green stuff for your
house I did like how that whole dialogue
exchange was in one shot though they
just let the actors act when it comes to
facing down my executioners I'd rather
meet the bastard standing right here
than to meet them running down some dark
alley
are on some Highway
oh
wowie Green Lasers green plants
Gia okay
come on let's Atomic blonde this
oh nice Sarah
before he got through yes
thank you
it's a little leg kick
boom murder them
yeah nice
all right
is he wearing white face is he white
chicksing this
Mission Impossible face pull billion
dollars of research and development and
all the Widow's Veil can cloak as your
face what about the rest of you that's
the newer version not this one we will
see it in a different property this is
what we're doing yes this is absolutely
I know exactly how far that is
nearly every avenger spilled blood in
the battle
ah woof in the aftermath some were sent
in to collect that DNA some of that
blood produces Iron Man armor
yes it definitely does nobody knew about
them but me
and the collectors so you are
responsible for all this yeah
how do you think I came back
whatever is in the crown I mean were you
aware that that's what he was trying to
do
the Harvest I from that early on yeah I
mean maybe just the blind threats from
Gravity he you know extrapolated out
Scandinavian Cemetery should have
brought my Scythe only dead man keep
secrets you taught me that son
dead men tell no Tales oh there it is
Ezekiel Fury why haven't you called any
of your special friends down you can't
keep depending on these superheroes to
swoop in and save our asses
it is when we're on the brink of World
War III none of them can defend the
world the way I can
that ain't enough yeah I don't know what
hope we have if that ain't enough maybe
I am
just dust I get what you're saying but
also you assemble the Avengers yeah
Priscilla in that honeymoon here Scrolls
like the cold
oh
she didn't know
you understand
uh I hope Olivia Coleman sticks around
yeah
like Fifth Element they do say
Darwin never sleeps
let's give our Extinction a nice leg up
why did they give her an actual
sympathetic scene yeah they're just
being cut just joy and murder yeah
three modes now
[Music]
oh yeah
there's the jacket
just for the eye patch I feel like you
could have kept a couple of these things
in the same drawer but
gotta have space yeah he's a big space
guy minimalism the patch is back he's
Fury again let's finish this
Boogie
Kobe smolders oh cause the TV I always
every time I'm I'm struck by that
alrighty
all righty well well ladies and
gentlemen I I feel like we should just
talk about it right now right now
because so much happened everything
there was just chaos oh my God there's a
crazy cacophony of events it's a display
of duplicitousness and an overwhelming
of any show it is a show of Duality and
duplicity
to be fair all right dichotomies koi
what is the first topic you think we
should talk about uh I like the leveling
up of the Betrayal of Fury that he had
no actual direct cause and I like that
Fury is always like recovering from his
own mistakes I like that we've seen now
the depths of that and that he didn't
really learn from his other lessons like
I feel like Nick Fury is this great uh
fallible character so I really enjoyed
him being the one responsible for
graphics uh original idea so harvesting
the ruins from the past yes because Nick
Fury in the comics is always like like
oh I did a thing and I've got to really
figure it out and how to recover it and
they they captured that here that is
true they did capture it well John what
did you think of his reasoning not to
call in The Avengers I thought it was uh
uh I'm of two minds about it I
understand on the one hand you know the
brilliant tactician's mind is certainly
one of the greater assets however given
the physical nature of this conflict I
do feel it's a little maybe
short-sighted not to involve someone who
could intervene on a cosmic level uh so
maybe not the best writing decision
given what we know this universe is
capable of it seems like the show being
very pressured to be like well we're
doing a ground level show so
we have to keep to that even though
we're going up against Scrolls who now
have super powers and who are gonna
start a World War some of our most tense
allies I don't know if you're aware he
got his eye patch back everything yeah
come on patch back I'm a pistol he is
fully a superhero again he is Nicholas J
Fury yes uh I mean I enjoyed the action
in this episode
um yeah the stunts were solid I enjoyed
um the the leveling up but I definitely
worry that there's one left
this episode of Shine for stunts and
foreseen work
I
think this was the first episode though
that okay yes I'll take it one subject
at a time
instead of compounding these two
subjects into one whoa what are you guys
doing we're at a buffet right now
this is a singular plot let's talk about
the action while we're talking about
Pros okay
it was it was fine it was good it was
good I like that I liked Priscilla yeah
and Emilia Clark Gaia bang banging it up
and uh them taking on a whole Squad of
people they're just that highly trained
and yeah I think in terms of gun play
and some violence even even the Mutiny
moment against graphic was well directed
well well done worked reasonably violent
and and
um hit just enough doesn't quite capture
anything I would say is visceral but
it's enjoyable uh and I think that it's
inventive at times like it's still you
know very good for a a TV show like it
does at the moments it's got little pops
I would I would say yes to that too I'm
sensing a certain tone here
this overall tone of this review is
exactly what you hope for
Creative versus the show started off
with a very different tone in these
reviews and it is it is uh it is taking
a certain direction that we will wait
till episode six before we get so
interesting that these shows tend to
have this we are not done with the
subjects course
all right this is the most
um Emilia Clarke we have gotten I think
is that correct I'd say this in the
first episode this was very heavily
focused on her
she gets to be more of her own character
as of this episode with no one to be
part of no one else's story to be a part
of it's more her journey through this I
think the writing and direction is all
uh making it feel flat though with what
she's going through gotta say it I gotta
call it out uh I don't think that this
should be like her the whole thing is
like she's grieving and she's gotta make
the she's got I don't know some
about going on a path or something right
yeah
and the entire time I was like oh yeah
this has like it seems like it's getting
lost in the void of where emotion should
be it's really interesting because the
show uh is all the same director it's
all the same mapped out budget it knows
what it needs to be and it's it's like
clockwork where these shows have a point
where it's like oh what happened yeah
it's beginning to feel a lot like
Christmas I don't want to say yeah
definitely
it needs to be more and less at once
it's becoming more by the numbers and
less exciting and less thrilling
less everything that was really great
about the first couple episodes
and you started to see a little bit of
signs in the third episode
and those signs started to magnify the
fourth and then here I'm like okay this
is the first time I feel like the shadow
has been cast in terms of the problems
that have been just kind of coming
through the weeds yeah taking over that
it is a it is a house on the sand that
is so that sand has been going over to
the house is is what I'm feeling because
it's by no means terrible no it is by no
means terrible it and maybe you guys
feel different which I'm uh good for you
if you are able to watch this and feel
differently when watching it uh but I
think a lot of the uh striking visual
components uh are are definitely way
more absent than ever and and yeah I'm
just talking from a storytelling point I
mean are there some MCU stuff of
exciting things to come maybe uh but at
this point I'm like that doesn't really
matter
matters is just making a good show and
this one uh we're not done with Goods
let's shift a little bit Olivia Goldman
Lily Coleman always believes
absolutely it's pure joy incarnate every
dialogue Choice like I like that you
could read the sentences from a lesser
actor and it'd be like well that's just
dialogue but she makes it Punchy like
she's really good at making dialogue
that shouldn't work sing and has great
chemistry with Sam Jackson
everybody's going yeah yeah but it's
impressive yeah and I like the way she
is very free to do a character and I
feel like Sam Jackson has been very free
to like put a lot of his own soul into
this I feel like he feels more
not just like Sam Jackson but someone
who's bringing you know the struggles of
their own life to a story that at least
wants to be big and impactful and also
he's got some of his flavor and Rhythm
and it's fun to see him in a Marvel
situation where he is allowed to really
kind of spread his wings a little bit in
the limited scenes that allow for that
uh I think my favorite character is
Priscilla she is the best character
she's the most interesting character or
the actress what is her name uh Charlene
Woodard she's she's just so natural and
and like I just love watching her she
draws me in she's just got so much life
every turn she takes I really enjoyed
the and I like that he pointed out the
dialogue it was like a lock-off shot we
just like lived in but that turn felt so
earned but also like her recovering from
the emotion also felt so worm like not
only does she have a moment of like raw
emotion because of something she said
but also like her and this is you being
this and like I was just really
impressed she seems to be one of the few
characters who convincingly at least who
like emotionally
exists at that fulcrum of like being in
the heart of a really tough
you know political like
geo-astropolitical situation but also
someone who was having like this
personal struggle and who has just a
really interesting
I don't know this is the life they've
given her as a character is easily the
most interesting yeah she doesn't try to
play it like overly dramatic she just
feels like a real human being and I love
that the history of her actually seems
like she has been here the whole time
you know and not just because this is a
character who you're implying has been
part of Nick Fury's life the past few
decades right and that he's had a secret
wife this whole time and Secret Lives
Secret Life Secret Life Invasion uh is
that you feel it it see it's like oh
yeah I can I actually got the sense that
she really not only understands her
character but the Marvel world and
everything like that I think she does it
I think she does a phenomenal job and
anytime she's been here I'm like you
have been a an absolute welcome addition
graphic
um is uh he's going down a path that I
saw a comments on one on our last video
it was like how did graphic end up a
better villain than Gore and you know
then it turned into a whole other
conversation about tiger watiti of
course but the uh but Graphics great I
think graphic is great
again it to me
everything just felt like it was sort of
getting undercut by trimming uh things
being too short and the just the overall
like because before it was like all
right maybe this is a little short but
I'm at least liking the way this is
being directed yeah and now I really
like the writing I like this scene yeah
now I'm like no a lot of this is not
really singing that loud anymore and so
and even the teamwork feels sacrificed
for it that's my point is like the
things that the actors are still showing
up and doing a great job but all the
scene work stuff that was once like well
this makes up for it is now not feeling
like it's making up for it now because
it's it it's it's like wow this is going
quicker and quicker when it when it
doesn't feel like the It doesn't feel
like intensity is ramping up it doesn't
feel like uh Stakes are ramping up even
if you have Graphics saying I'm raising
the state it does not feel like things
are truly ramping up it it just seems
like they're now just trying to get it
over with it yeah a little bit and to me
it feels like like a missed opportunity
in this sense and we'll see how it ends
you know it could there could be a
tremendous finale coming our way but I
feel like this is highlighting something
that has been a curiosity to me since
this show started which was okay I know
Falcon and the Winter Soldier was an
attempt to do something kind of in this
vein but that was hampered by a lot of
outside real world circumstances this
doesn't have that so now we're moving
into a piece of the story where I'm like
okay this is all very familiar the bad
guy for whatever his political
aspirations are and his you know his
Uprising you know whole philosophy is
he's basically just trying to get a
magic McGuffin so he can get really
powerful and then cause a lot of
Destruction and then we gotta stop it
and that's pretty familiar and it
doesn't really take this whole world war
three and like ooh we're gonna create
like a false flag situation or something
where you know we have them bomb us to
create this spark of oh our people are
gonna think we're being attacked and all
the Russians are gonna think they're
being attacked like it it pays face
value to that stuffer or lip service to
that stuff but I don't really think that
they've committed to like having a
political thriller that's really a
political thriller yeah
um yeah what are you gonna do
you know it's not like you can make this
stuff better
it's just it's really interesting part
it just started so strong for me and it
is an odd tradition of of Disney plus
yeah like Loki got better
um and and like Wanda Vision was like
five out of six for me but like the the
rest of all felt like diminishing
returns like in one way or another
whether it's Hawkeye being something
that's really fun and novel and Buddy
copy but then like as soon as they
introduce a character we want to be you
know more like something we know it's
just like oh and then it's just the last
the last little bit of that show felt
left like it Falcon the Winter Soldier
it felt like it had to take a left turn
in order to recover I don't know it's
just it's really interesting because you
know the show is gonna end away when you
start making it yeah it's just really
odd to like let that happen again yeah
proportions do seem very strange for the
way they've done a lot of these show and
yeah it's like one Division and Loki set
this tone where you're like yeah cool
like you could have maybe gone one or
one more but like mostly everything's
there and now lately it's either been
like too long or Too Short like and yeah
there's like a sweet spot that I don't
know if they have found more werewolf by
night yeah or one-offs yeah all righty
well guys
ah this is my least favorite episode of
the season so far I'm gonna leave it at
that we'll see how the entire package
ends up being delivered by the end here
is your least favorite yeah
probably
it's got the least cohesive amalgamation
of everything there are still good
moments but yeah this is not the most
cohesive it's goddess moments but
everything constantly just kept feeling
like being cut too short and so you kept
feeling like they were like onto the
next thing onto the next thing wait
there was a lot of like Martini shot
Martini you would think that there would
be a button or some kind of Coda to a
lot of things or or things would
constantly feel like okay now we're
starting to cook oh wait we're cutting
away again and we're resetting the build
of momentum yeah odd very odd
penultimate
alrighty
well you're looking at a three satisfied
fans man oh man do we feel complete
um what do you guys think let us know
down below but we'll of course come back
for the finale
hopeful hopeful it's gonna be good that
they that they go you know what let's
make this great
um
gray tick
subscribe
this is like okay
thoughts down below we will be a coffee
coach come visit us thank you thank you
guys for um for being here yep yep um
hey I think let's shout out a patron why
don't why don't we do that after that
exit they're gonna love it whoever
I want to be on this episode I am this
is the one
this is what I want please please shout
me out flev Doran flavor are you liking
it are you liking this flavor you're uh
you're a big fan of all these properties
you you you're like yeah this is my jam
right here this is what I want flip door
is a good scroll name yeah pretty sure
he made this exact same thing
to dig back in the archives did we do
Flav in another I remember every single
time someone repeats a joke
I like that you don't remember other
stuff you've got this weird bag of like
I've been remembered Joker that's gonna
be my thing because it's not funny now
and now I'm upset 100 original joke well
that's how much it's a scroll name yeah
it's level we'll correct this but it's
like I'm in my patreon either way while
this episode did not fill us with life
you fill us with life constantly so
because your energy is is like when do
you remember at the end of Pokemon uh
the movie
no he actually didn't do that in the
movie uh in the movie when we thought
Ash was dead yeah and then all the
Pokemon cried and their tears welcome
back on love yeah they resurrected him
yeah from the dead that's where you are
like for us you are the Pokemon's tears
you're the very best that no one was
before humanoids for life
so thank you fled for being you and for
always being here and I hope you have a
great week samsies
[Music]